Hello world. It's a Raj. In this video,
we're going to compare the most popular
deep learning frameworks out there right
now to see what works best.
The deep learning space is
exploding with frameworks.
Right now it's like every single week
some major tech company decides to open
source their own deep learning library
and that's not including the dozens of
deep learning frameworks being released
every single week on get hub by cowboy
developers. How many layers you get.
Let's start off with psychic learn.
Psychic was made to provide an easy to
use interface for developers to use off
the shelf.
General purpose machine
learning algorithms for both
supervised and unsupervised
learning.
Psyche provides functions that let you
apply classic machine learning algorithms
like support vector machines,
logistic regression's and k
nearest neighbor very easily,
but the one type of machine
learning algorithm it doesn't
let you implement is a
neural network.
It doesn't provide GPU support either,
which is what helps neural network scale.
Since like two months ago,
pretty much every single general purpose
algorithm that cycle or an implemented
has since been implemented in tensorflow
psychic. You just got learned.
There's also cafe,
which was basically the first mainstream
production grade deep learning library
started in 2013 but cafe
isn't very flexible.
Think of a neural network as a
computational graph. In Cafe,
each node is considered a layer,
so if you want new layer types you have
to define the full forward backward
ingredient updates. These
layers are building blocks
that are unnecessarily big.
There's an endless list of them that
you can pick from in tensorflow.
Each note is considered a tensor operation
like matrix at or Matrix multiply or
convolution, and a layer can be defined
as a composition of those operations.
So tensorflow is building blocks are
smaller, which allows for more modularity.
Cafe also requires a lot
of unnecessary verbosity.
If you want to support
both the CPU and the GPU,
you need to implement extra functions
for each and you'd have to define your
model using a plain text editor.
That is just ghetto model should
be defined programmatically
because it's better
for modularity between different
components. Also, cafes,
main architect now works
on the tensorflow team.
We're all out of cafe,
but speaking of modularity,
let's talk about care.
Ross terrace has been the goto source
to get started with deep learning for
awhile because it provides a very high
level API to build deep learning models.
Kara sits on top of the
other deep learning libraries
like piano in tensorflow.
It uses an object oriented design,
so everything is considered an object
be that layers, models, optimizers,
and all the parameters of the model can
be accessed as object properties like
model dot layers three dot output.
We'll give you the output tensor for
the third layer in the model and model
dealt layers three dealt weights is
a list of symbolic weight tensors.
This is a cleaner interface as opposed
to the functional approach of making
layers functions that create weights
when being called great documentation.
It's all Gucci. Yes, I'm bringing that
back, but because it's so general purpose,
it lacks on the side of performance.
Chaos has been known to have performance
issues when used with a tensorflow
backend since it's not
really optimized for it,
but it does work pretty well
with the Theono backends.
Two frameworks that are neck and neck
right now in the race to be the best
library for both research and
industry are tensorflow and piano.
Piano currently outperforms
tensorflow on a single GPU,
but tensorflow outperforms the Yanno for
parallel execution across multiple gps.
Deanna has got more documentation because
it's been around for awhile and it's
got native windows support,
which tensorflow flow
doesn't yet dammit windows.
In terms of syntax, let's just take a
look at some code to see some differences.
We're going to compare two
scripts in tensorflow and theone.
They both do the same thing,
initialized symfony data and then learn
the line of best fit for that data so it
can predict future data points.
Let's look at the first step in both
tensorflow Angiano or generating the data
pretty much the same way
using num py or raise,
so there's not really a difference there.
Let's look at the model
initialization parts.
This is the basic y equals mx plus
B slope formula, intention flow.
It doesn't require any special treatment
of the x and y variables. They're just,
they're natively,
but in piano we have to specifically say
that the variables are symbolic inputs
to the function.
The tension flow syntax of defining
the B w variables is cleaner.
Then we implement our gradient descent
function, which is what helps us learn.
We're trying to minimize the
mean squared error over time,
which is what makes our
model more accurate.
As we train the syntax for defining
what we're minimizing is pretty similar.
Then when we look at the actual
optimizer which helps us do that,
we'll notice a difference in syntax.
Again,
tensorflow just gives you access to a
bunch of optimizers right out of the box.
Things like gradient descent or Adam Piano
makes you do this from scratch and we
have our training function which is
again more verbose. See the trend here.
Deanna so far is making us
implement more code than tensorflow,
so it seems to give us more fine grained
control but at the cost of readability.
Finally we'll get to the
actual training part itself.
They look pretty identical but tension
flows methodology of encapsulating the
computational graph peels
conceptually cleaner than pianos.
Tensorflow is just growing so fast
that it seems inevitable that whatever
feature it lacks right now because of
how new it is, it will gain very rapidly.
I mean just look at the amount of
activity happening in the tensorflow repo
versus the theatro repo on get hub right
now and while Kara serves as an easy
use wrapper around different libraries,
it's not optimized for tensorflow.
A better alternative if you want to
learn and get started easily with deep
learning is TF learn, which is basically
care os but optimized for tensorflow.
So to sum things up, the best library
to use for research is tensorflow,
the world class researchers that both
open AI and deep mind are now using it for
production.
The Best Library to use is still tends
to flow since it scales better across
multiple Gpu then its closest
competitor piano. Lastly for learning,
the best library use is TF learn,
which is a high level
wrapper around tensorflow.
That lets you get started really easily.
Also,
shout out to Raho Deo for being
able to generate an upbeat mid.
I file a bad ass of the week. Please
subscribe for more programming videos.
For now. I've got to go worship tensorflow
some more. So thanks for watching.